emmanuel macron likes to style himself
as a man with a vision for europe he's
pushed hard for an eu army he's called
for greater integration reform and
strengthening of the single currency
though he has wrote back a bit on that
one at least all the while germany under
the stoic guidance of mother merkel has
smiled and nodded but whenever push came
to shove she made clear who was boss one
shouldn't benefit from european
solidarity while playing against other
member states
solidarity among partners should never
lead to a debt union it should instead
be about helping others to help
themselves
the two have history so before macron
even occupied the elysee he held sway as
the french economy minister and doing
talks to help greece avoid crippling
austerity measures merkel put her foot
down
according to emmanuel merkel ordered
holland to keep macron out of greek
negotiations merkel's spell was every
bit as powerful as i had imagined with
the merkel era slowly but surely winding
down we all know that she's leaving big
shoes to fill makon is clearly keen to
step into them but can he during his
tenure at the elise the former
investment banker has ruffled more than
a few feathers not just in europe but
also across the globe
what we are currently experiencing is
the brain death of nato nato only works
if the guarantor of last resort
functions as such
they are francis president the french
president has found rather drastic words
to express his views i don't think such
a sweeping judgment is appropriate
obviously we have to take our destiny in
our own hands but the transatlantic
partnership for us is absolutely
indispensable
relations with other countries have
often appeared to be rosy we do have a
very special
relationship in fact i'll get that
little piece of dandruff
we have to make him perfect he is
perfect thank you and your delicious
wife for your warm welcome it's the
perfect organization of this trip thanks
to you and lucy thank you very much mr
prime minister thank you very much
there is a very very strong atlanticist
movement in france the so-called
liberals like liberation
the greens the socialist party et cetera
we've always been very afro-american and
anti-russian and macron
i think he's sort of somewhat in between
but macron doesn't have a i think a
clear idea what to do how to do it first
of all i don't agree that merkel was a
leader of europe i mean she was not i
mean she was in a sense because germany
is so powerful but maybe your successor
will be the leader of europe i don't
know i mean
back home certainly is not going to
fulfill that hole
however underlying tensions have often
surfaced showing that the ties aren't
quite as strong as macron would like to
make out
latitude
the united states has shown towards the
submarine deal clearly illustrates the
point we've been making for months
namely that political dialogue within
nato is
non-existent even here at home he's had
his work cut out while being feted by
the international press macron has found
himself all too often irritating the
french who have not been afraid to lash
out
[Music]
he just doesn't come across as strong to
me as like angela merkel did he's got a
lot of issues going on in his own
country right now both pandemic with
a lot of the unions he's got high
unemployment rates with certain areas
we've got a large uh minority population
there's a lot of areas that internally
which could potentially put additional
pressure and distract him in that area
from a greater european side i mean if
he does
is successful in a european area it may
it actually may give him a better view
within internally within the country as
well
but he's got some he's got several
internal issues that he needs to uh deal
with as well
as the empress of europe merkel exit the
stage macron might think the time has
come for his star to shine however with
the fight of his life to retain the
presidency here in france not too far
away he could struggle to keep the dual
attention of both the home and european
audiences and right now it is far from
clear whether macboon's political talent
can match his grandiose ambitions
charlotte dubinsky rt paris
you